hi i've been reading a lot of books
lately and i do want to share
because it's been a lot it's been
it's been a lot i will say i'm entering
a kind of reading renaissance
personally not like that we aren't in a
reading renaissance
first off reading ebooks through the
library is perfect because you have this
limited amount of time to read you have
like 21 days for each book
i see all these books i like and i
download like 20.
if someone else is waiting and they have
a hold on the book it'll say like one
person is waiting or two people are
waiting or three people are waiting for
this book and then that's what kicks me
in the ass because i'm thinking if i'm
not reading this book it's just sitting
here when other people want to be
reading they're waiting on me
and then the pressure's cooking and i'm
like oh i need to
i need to read this before these people
get mad at me so the first book i want
to mention today
is a masterpiece definitely one of the
best books i've read in
several years one of my new favorites
although it
has like ruined my life it is depressing
it is so depressing i wasn't even
prepared for how depressing this book
was but oh my god it's a masterpiece
it's perfect in every way
i wouldn't change a word butcher's
crossing by john
williams some of you i assume might know
this
writer from a famous book he wrote which
is like a cult book
i haven't read stoner i read butcher's
crossing because i like westerns
the whole book is about this massive
critique of
emersonian 19th century
transcendentalism the main character
is this young guy who thinks that
he can go travel west believes that if
he
joined nature he can transcend being
human and just become
part of this bigger world whatever i
mean he ends up
forming a buffalo hunting party because
he believes that will truly bring him
into
nature there are twists and turns in
ways that aren't like
character twists or whatever it's just
like you don't know what the [ __ ] nature
is gonna do you read this book and you
are beaten down
and this character gets beaten down
slowly it's not sudden it's not just
like suddenly like oh wow nature is
[ __ ]
and there is no god i think about the
movie
grizzly man which is a documentary about
the guy who
you know wanted to live with bears and
lived with bears and thought he was so
connected to nature there's this
emphasis on the massive
indifference of the universe and it is
terrifying and
sad this character who believes that
there's this magnificence to
have in nature which there is there's
ton of beauty but there's just as
equally as much
violence and chaos and disorder and
misery
and it's also a critique of american uh
exceptionalism westward expansion
you don't really know where the story is
going for a while it's not trying to
force any perspective it's just saying
like
observe what happens you know here's a
character who thinks they know
what the world is made of who who knows
what nature is made of let's see what
they think when they
actually go out into nature beautifully
written this
book was so enjoyable but so
crushing another book i read or another
type of book i read
elmore leonard books very prolific crime
writer he wrote westerns early in his
career but
later wrote crime fiction his books were
adapted into movies
like jackie brown out of sight get
shorty i just started reading them and
have been obsessed
i think because style his humor but
really the style of the writing which is
so stripped down
conveys so much with so little i've just
been obsessed it's addictive
especially when you're reading you know
huge fantasy books that to have a short
you know 250 page elmore leonard novel
it's so nice and fun and i've read i've
just been
reading so many of them first one i read
was called pronto which introduced the
raylen givens character
which was used in the show justified
haven't seen justified i read
writing the rap same character and
firing the whole which is uh
a novella all really good stories i
would say pronto was the best one it was
also the first one i read
one of the downsides to elmore leonard
novels is that things just sort of
happen
in a lot of ways the plots are great but
realistic to a point where just these
characters
they do things stuff happens and then
the story ends elmore leonard was not a
plotter
i love seeing the difference between the
plotters and the panthers you know
reading brandon sanderson who
is very structured and has a thorough
plot
you can read a sanderson book and go
through hundreds
sometimes hundreds of pages and feel
like things aren't going anywhere
and wondering what's the point and it's
just all build up and then you get to an
excellent climax and then you read
something like elmore leonard you read
stephen king where
you go from chapter to chapter going wow
these are
interesting characters these are
interesting scenes i wonder where this
is going and then sometimes it doesn't
always
go anywhere so like one of the books i
read which was uh
kind of disappointing was maximum bob
and it just kind of
you know ends get shorty was good but i
had seen the movie already again just
kind of ends
there's not really any satisfying
conclusion the characters are great i
mean that's
the thing about elmore leonard if i were
to recommend one i'd say read
read pronto so in a recent video i
talked about
uh jean patrick manchette
i believe that's how it's pronounced
french crime writer wrote primarily in
the 70s and 80s
tough gritty short crime books that are
sometimes
really funny i read fatale was really
short almost novella length it was like
100 pages
i was pretty disappointed it was
basically just about this
femme fatale character and she seems
pretty amoral
for most of the book until she has a
change of heart it got pretty goofy
and that's my problem is that i should
have gone in expecting a comedy because
it was just so over the top like
unrealistic characters were just like
really two-dimensional
by the end it literally turns into like
a slasher film
killing all these guys just like
single-handedly like not enough
was built up to make it feel real in any
way didn't enjoy that much
but it was short so you know but the
real
manchet title i loved the mad and the
bad
i don't know what its title is in french
what a weird
chaotic insane book this is really the
title the mad and the bad is perfect i
can't even i can't even get into the
plot it's so insane it starts off with
a maid who is hired by this this like
billionaire
all we know that this billionaire's
nephew who's
who's a kid is a total little monster
like he's a little demon child
this billionaire wants to have him
killed basically trying to frame
the maid who he hired from the insane
asylum for
the kids murder things start to go
haywire
it was bizarre but grounded in a way
so that when the violence really came
and ramped up and got
sort of out of control it felt real it
felt like i could picture it
oh man i i want to read it again because
it was so fun
dark humor just pitch black humor
amazing set pieces
check it out it's so good and then real
quick uh i just want to mention that i
read a non-fiction book
the assassination of julius caesar by
michael parenti like a
people's history of ancient rome
basically analyzes how
caesar's popular reforms were extremely
unpopular to the
uh aristocrats in rome like cicero
and i just i learned so much because i
don't know a ton about ancient rome
so much of what we know about ancient
rome and really about all of history
is written by the wealthy our
understanding of julius caesar is going
to be warped and understood
and and of any kind of popular reformer
or any kind of popular figure
it's definitely worth looking into
especially if you're
interested in ancient rome so yeah there
you go i read um
i did good i did good this last month
i've been reading more than usual
hoping to start malazan or the wheel of
time
i don't know i have to see what i don't
know if i should start malazan or the
wheel of time first
anyways thank you for watching that's
all i have to say have a great
you know week
yeah yeah bye